Ось так починалася ця теледуель.
Трохи менше ніж через дві години стало ясно -
головний суперник Анґели Меркель на цих виборах,
Мартін Шульц,
не зміг переломити ситуацію.
За результатами опитування глядачів, проведеного на замовлення телеканалу ARD,
чинну канцлерку назвали переконливішою
55 відсотків опитаних, її суперника -
35 відсотків.
97 хвилин чотири журналісти ставили
їм свої запитання.
Найголовніші теми: відносини з Туреччиною, КНДР, президент США Дональд Трамп, а також
"дизельний скандал". Але найбільше часу
суперники присвятили кризі біженців.
Мартін Шульц закинув Меркель не узгоджене з партнерами
по Євросоюзу рішення почати пускати до Європи
сотні тисяч біженців восени 2015-го року:
Ви заявили за тих обставин,
що вони можуть приїхали до Німеччини, і це було абсолютно правильно.
Але усього цього можна було б уникнути,
і мені шкода, фрау Меркель,
але краще було б залучити наших європейських сусідів
перед таким рішенням.
Тодішня ситуація була дуже драматичною.
За тих обставин ми діяли згідно з Конституцією,
її першою статтею, що людська гідність є недоторканною.
Про відносини з Росією і конфлікт в Україні суперники не згадували.
Проте їм поставили питання про рішення
колишнього канцлера Німеччини Ґергарда Шредера
прийняти пропозицію російського уряду та працювати
у раді директорів компанії "Роснефть",
яка нині перебуває під санкціями ЄС у зв'язку
з анексією Криму.
І Меркель, і Шульц були єдині щодо цього:
Це погано.
Погано. Це підриває санкції, які запровадив Європейський Союз.
Це дуже сумна ситуація.
Він не повинен був цього робити.
Німці дивилися ці теледебати переважно удома чи в кнайпах,
проте були й такі, які спеціально
прийшли до кінотеатрів.
після того, що ці дві партії довгі роки
складали урядову коаліцію, вони маже нічим не відрізняються.
Думаю, фрау Меркель була більш переконлива.
Мені здалося, вони були десь на одному рівні.
Меркель уперше вдалося перемогти на теледебатах із такою
великою перевагою. Проте
її ж однопартійці - християнські демократи
застерігають -
результат виборів після телебедатів аж ніяк не вирішений наперед.
Тепер важливо - переконати німців все ж прийти на
виборчі дільниці, навіть якщо всі опитування і
пророкують перемогу Анґелі Меркель.